[Musique]
sur cinq personnes interrogées quatre
vous connaissent
depuis combien de temps vous êtes là au
bord de la route près de Bayonne sur la
nationale 10h 10 ans et du matin au soir
ici au bord de la route vous tricotez
ouais pourquoi
parce que parce que ça me plaît et puis
j'aime ça
sans pour un client j'en ai fait environ
beaucoup alors vos vaches là sont
derrière dans le pré et au lieu de les
de les garder en le faisant rien vous
faites cela oui je fais ça
mais
le soir lorsque vous rentrez chez vous
vous tricotez encore fait un peu oui
vous avez 36 ans vous devriez encore
tricoter combien de temps au long terme
[Musique]